merci nous sommes effectivement de
retour sur le plateau de la voie est
libre ou une discutons ce matin de la
loisne macron et plus précisément des
professions juridiques réglementées avec
cécile untermaier député socialiste de
saône-et-loire président de la mission
parlementaire sur ces professions
françoise david eray le président du
conseil régional des notaires et thierry
berland l'ancien bâtonnier membre du
conseil de l'ordre des avocats là on n'a
pas réussi d'un autre point que qui a
été abordé par emmanuel macron dans son
projet de loi c'est la révision des
grilles tarifaires
actuellement il donc il ya des les
tarifs d administration judiciaire des
huissiers de justice des notaires sont
vraiment à réglementer les expliquez
nous en quelques mots comment ça
fonctionne si vous voulez bien
c'est effectivement important de le
savoir essayez de deux remarques
préalables nous ne sommes pas libres de
notre tarif le tarif est fixé par décret
nous avons l'obligation d'imposer nous
sommes d'ailleurs contrôlé sur
l'application réelle du du tarif tel
qu'il est prévu par le décret nous ne
pouvons pas le module et ça c'est le
premier point d'autre part il y à une
confusion parce que nous avons laissé
passer l'expression frais de notaire qui
est une hérésie puisqu'en réalité nous
percevons beaucoup de taxes pour le
compte de l'état de l'ordre de 22
milliards sans aucun coût pour l'état et
c'est une part extrêmement importante de
ce que l'on appelle les frêles de 80 85
enfants oui ça passe ça dépend des
montants mais oui alors par contre pour
ce qui est du tarif
nous pensons pas ce que nous sommes je
voulais déjà dit d'accord sur une sur
une réforme nous pensons qu
effectivement ce tarif doit être revue
parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'est pas
suffisamment transparent il était
vraiment complexe nous mêmes en a
parfois du mal à déterminer le tarif
applicable vous parlez trop de la part
de la loi robien la part du chiffre
d'affaires vérité doit alors suivant les
actes c'est relativement compliqué c'est
vrai une manque de transparence et sam
vous l'avez constaté en irlande tout
citoyen d'ailleurs content tout citoyen
constate parce que quand il va chez son
notaire il va chez une personne de
confiance mais il n'a aucune idée du
coût que va représenter
l'acte quasiment pas enfin en tout cas
pas très sains précise donc il faut
qu'on travaille effectivement à la
visibilité à la transparence le là
dessus on est d'accord ce qui va quand
même changé dans la loi et sur laquelle
la mission d'information que j'ai menée
est d'accord c'est que on va introduire
si vous voulez le torride l'autorité de
la concurrence une autorité indépendante
qui va travailler rebasé tous ses tarifs
en concertation bien évidemment avec la
profession mais c'est une autorité
indépendante et qui est quand même
composé de deux personnes de très haute
qualité compétentes qui vont pouvoir
mener ce travail extrêmement complexe
j'espère dans des délais relativement
rapide et cette grille tarifaire sera
public c'est à dire que la vie de la
concurrence sur cette grille tarifaire
sera public et ensuite cette grille il
sera arrêté par la garde des sceaux
c'est à dire qu'on a quand même veiller
c'était une demande forte de la
profession
juridique et elle avait raison en ce
sens que
la réglementation soit bien toujours
sous la main delà de la chancellerie ça
sera le cas mais nous aurons une
autorité indépendante qui établira ses
tarifs ce qu'on attend une du mal à
comprendre pourquoi c'est pas
transparent parce que s'est fixés par
l'état et ce plaisir à 30 c'est
transparent c'est juste très complexe
donc vous dites que on ne sait pas
combien va coûter un acte sinon on donne
des devis on explique combien ça va
coûter c'est à dire que lorsqu'il s'agit
d'acheter une maison il ya un avant
contrat qui est signé lynne évident qu
on sait très précisément à ce moment là
qu'elle va être le coup ce sont les
notaires romaine qui nous disent que
c'est très difficile de pouvoir afficher
les prix et l'entré jeu j'en suis bien
d'accord que je suis à la faire c'est un
cas d'espèce puisque le barème n'est pas
le même suivant la nature de l'acte ii
suivante qu'il s'agit d'une vente cissé
ou d'une succession ou d'une donation
donc nous sommes d'accord et nous nous
nous attendons cela aussi par contre
c'est vrai que l'autorité de la
concurrence a été saisie et n'a pas
encore rendu son rapport à ma
connaissance ce qui nous inquiète un peu
c'est que c'est un regard économique
alors que nous souhaiterions que ce soit
plutôt sous l'égide du ministère de la
justice oui mais moi très sincèrement
j'entends vos préoccupations et je pense
qu'il est extrêmement important
effectivement que la chancellerie soit
choix soit votre ministère de tutelle
mais pour autant la chancellerie n'est
pas du tout équipés pour travailler sur
les grilles tarifaires et il nous semble
qu'une nouvelle gouvernance dans la
carte notamment des zones carences et du
nombre de notaires il n'y a pas ça ne va
pas s'arrêter à la où il faut créer des
postes et des notaires et bien que ce
soit avec l'aide de l'autorité de la
concurrence je pense que c'est au
contraire une considération qui est
apporté à votre profession et un soutien
éclairant qui sera utile à tous les
avocats ce pas un problème
il n'y a pas de paris faut prévoir deux
des avocats
une convention
c'est alors là un élément qui je trouve
assez bien dans la loue à mâcon c'est
qu'il rende obligatoire
l'établissement d'une convention écrite
dans tous les cas c'était c'était bien
trop lointain par son avocat c'est une
recommandation d'un forte de la
profession et l'avocat qui ne donne pas
d'informations préalables s'expose à des
contestations et il est souvent
sanctionnés à cause de ça donc il ya une
concurrence totale et une liberté de
fixation des duperies dévastation en
revanche h et marginalement il est vrai
dans la foule qu'on appelle la
postulation se tenir là qu'est ce que çà
et là c'est le monopole de
représentation d'une partie devant une
juridiction donc cette représentation
territoriale au cas d'espèce
actuellement devant le tribunal de
grande instance et éventuellement devant
la cour mais il n'y a pas de tarif il
n'ya un tarif que devant le tribunal de
grande instance qu'on appelle l'état de
frais alors pour que les choses soient
très claires tout savoir de quoi on
parle
un état de fait classique d'avocats
demande tj il oscille entre 200 et 400
euros les gros état de fait sont assez
rares c'est vraiment assez peu alors
c'est un tarif il est alors pour le non
professionnel peut-être pas facile à
comprendre je veux dire il est
indiscutable dans son résultat il ya une
matière est une manière de calculer et
c'est vérifiable et je dois dire que le
tarif il faut quand même le rappeler
c'est pas un privilège c'est une
garantie pour les usagers ça veut dire
c'est vrai totalement pour les autres
professions très partiellement pour les
avocats c'est à dire que le
professionnel ne va pas fixer les prix
n'importe comment et le tarif protège le
consommateur il suffit qu'ils soient
modernisées contrôler d'ailleurs il ya
des pays les avocats en allemagne sont
totalement tarifées dans leur activité
judiciaire totalement je le dis bien et
c'est le tribunal qui dit dans cette
matière à l'écran votre difficulté 7 ans
et ça c'est très clair pour les usagers
ce
que je voulais dire là je trouve quand
on parle du tarif on voit combien quand
même les professions d'avocat les
profession de notaire sont très
différentes dans et que effectivement la
loi n'a pas facilité le travail parce
que on a fait des amalgames qui était
qui n'avait pas lieu d'être s'agissant
indépendamment du revenu on n'est pas du
tout dans les mêmes dans les mêmes
façons de travailler on a l'avocat
travailler vraiment une profession
libérale il vend son cabinet et ils vont
sa clientèle il ya des zones horaires
libres et le notaire lui quand même dans
une dans un dispositif beaucoup plus
fermé avec des garanties mutuelles
un droit de présentation qui est un
droit de présenter son successeur et
qu'on impose en quelque sorte à l'achat
1 est à l'achat la chambre à l'étal est
la chancellerie si si c'est notre terre
correspond aux normes il est hors de
question que la chancellerie disent non
puisque c'est un droit de présentation
donc on est quand même dans un
dispositif complètement différent donc
gré fécond et non jamais je pense que
les problèmes sont pas du tout les mêmes
et on aurait dû effectivement travailler
différemment parce que je pense que la
profession d'avocat mérite une attention
particulière en ce moment il ya un vrai
sujet que vous vous sans doute que vous
prenez au niveau des ordres sais que
vous avez beaucoup quand même deux
jeunes sur tout notre territoire qui ne
sont pas dans des situations très très
facile quand ils sont avocats et on doit
s'adapter s'interroger on doit
s'interroger sur l'aide juridictionnelle
que qui est sous-évalué comme vous
l'avez dit sur le financement
en soutien de l'état de l'aide
juridictionnelle qui ne peut pas être
apportés si elle doit être apportées par
la profession par la seule profession d
avocat donc on a des questions
extrêmement importante s'agissant de la
postulation c'est vrai que ça nous a
occupé la postulation c'est que un
avocat à paris qui vient juger une
affaire qui veut une affaire jugée à
chalon va devoir prendre un avocat du
barreau de chalon ça présente des
avantages et ça permet le financement
des barreaux locaux donc moins je
demande dans ma mission qu'il y ait
qu'une étude d'impact pour voir les
effets donc un l'impact d'une telle
décision au niveau d'une postulation qui
n'existerait plus qu'au niveau des cours
d'appel c'est à dire de permettre un
avocat de chalon d'aller plaider à mâcon
où et dijon sans avoir recours
nécessairement à un avocat postulants le
simplement s'il en a envie un avocat
correspondant avec un tarif donc on va
nous travailler sur cette question je
pense que dans le projet de loi en tant
que rapporteur pour avis je ferai valoir
7 7 7 c'est cette idée avec en revanche
une suppression du carif s'inquiète
beaucoup notamment alors plus que lyon
ou encore s'inquiètent beaucoup le
barreau par exemple de faire une halte
70 ans qu'il est pour la cour d'appel de
paris
c'est pour cette la cour d'appel est un
bon rempart je
pars pour d'histoire tout le monde le
sait les objectifs de la chancellerie
c'est d'ouvrir totalement dessus plaisir
les autorités qu'elles n'y sont plus et
c'est vraiment vous avez reçu vous avez
entendu le 19 novembre dans le cadre de
votre mission monsieur henri robert
premier président de la cour d'appel de
dijon président de la conférence des
premiers présidents de france qui a dit
que la réforme très brutale de la région
la procédure devant la cour d'appel la
suppression des avoués et l'arrivée d'un
certain nombre d'avocats dans son
ressort 500 avait troublé assez
fortement ses conditions d'exercice
les magistrats sont en réalité assez
satisfait d'avoir des interlocuteurs
avocats de proximité car ils peuvent
mettre en place des conventions locales
président robert en parlait et ça c'est
très bon
je n'ai pas mauvais d'avoir un local et
qui prend d'ailleurs qu'il faut un
second avocat de la postulation là on en
est on est bien d'accord
un dernier mot
qu'est ce que vous attendez maintenant
la de ce qui va se passer à l'assemblée
nationale
nous aimerions avoir une concertation au
jeu c'est toi qui était proposée par le
par le ministère de l'économie nous ne
nous a pas entendus vous nous avez reçu
votre commission a reçu un certain
nombre de professionnels nous n'avons
pas eu du tout ce qui me décharge avec
avec le ministère de l'économie qui nous
impose des problématiques qui nous font
peur notamment au niveau du tarif avec
cette grille tarifaire avec la
possibilité de négocier dû discuter ce
tarif ce qui nous semble aller à
l'encontre la sécurité juridique que
nous apportons nous confirmer votre
apportera donc essentiel là pour la
discussion commence le 22 janvier
bien avant la commission spéciale est
installée la semaine prochaine mardi
prochain le rapport sera présenté à la
commission des lois le 26 de non le
mercredi prochain
le 17 et la loi sera examiné dès le 5
janvier avec sans doute un débat dans
l'hémicycle mais ça peut changer le 22
janv de même de janvier c'est bien ça
merci beaucoup en tout cas nous avons
tome de cette émission merci à tous
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et pour
vos explications nécessaires je vous
rappelle que je vous avais que vous
pouvez voir ou revoir cette émission sur
notre site internet google point france
3 points et faire tout de suite le 12/13
se poursuit sur france 3 avec le
développement de l'actualité en france
et à l'étranger très bel après-midi à
tous
merci beaucoup c'est beau